it turns out according to new reports
the FBI may have had a spy in or
interacting with the Trump campaign
during the 2016 election a government
spy in the campaign that sounds like a
pretty important piece of information
that the Obama administration may have
been spying on a rival campaign you
think but for some reason we're only
just learning about it now why is that
apparently because the FBI and the DOJ
deliberately hid that information from
Congress of course Congress has
authority over the FBI it's not the
other way around as much as the FBI
would like to believe that
so this deception would be gross
misconduct at minimum but of course
Groesbeck Contin misconduct would be
nothing new in the FBI of Jim Comey dan
bun Gina was a former Secret Service
agent an NYPD officer and he joins us
tonight dan this is one of those stories
that's so shocking if true that a you
don't want to believe it's true that our
government would do the Obama
administration would have done something
like that but B you have to press
carefully on the details what do we know
about this yeah you're right Tucker for
the sake of the constitutional republic
you pray this story isn't true there's
no partisan advantage this is I mean the
very idea of having big are god-given
rights has been shredded if in fact they
can't produce hard evidence of any crime
yet and yet a human intelligence asset
may have been inserted in your political
rivals campaign I mean how this isn't
front-page news on every newspaper
across the globe is stunning but Tucker
that that's not it though keep in mind
just a couple weeks ago Devin Nunez on
this network in an interview with Maria
Bartiromo had another bombshell that
there was no official foreign
intelligence through official channels
passed into the United States
that was a huge bombshell because notice
what he didn't say he didn't say it
didn't pass through unofficial channels
so we know two things potentially that
information was laundered through the
State Department and potentially the US
Senate and you know that was potentially
a human asset in the Trump campaign
unbelievable has is there any precedents
for this has this ever happened before
has it ever been
alleged before in a presidential
campaign not in the United States I'm
sure it's happened in some spy novels
and in in some third-world countries
where this may be common but Tucker this
is a story so unbelievable on its face
that I've said to people it's like the
sickest spy novel I've ever read and
accept it actually happened if you were
to give this to a book agent and tell
them it was a story about the United
States government they very well might
laugh at you and say this is so absurd
this could never happen but Tucker there
I mean I have my suspicions about who
this asset is as do many others by the
way this is going to be explosive though
when this name comes out because the
list of suspects is very short and there
are some very suspicious people who are
connected to people within our
intelligence community now but this is
the key point Tucker also connected to
political operators working for
Democrats while connected to foreign
intelligence assets as well this is
really serious stuff this isn't a joke
and like you said before I really wish
none of this was true but it appears
sadly that it is well I mean it would be
a crime to begin with do you think it's
true do you is there evidence that the
FBI was receiving information from
within the Trump campaign during the
campaign yes and there there not only
that there's I don't I believe there's
more than one source for the FBI now
whether that's where there was more than
one source that was paid maybe an
entirely different story
I believe that based on reporting Tucker
that's already out there so you know I
know a lot of people out there love the
conspiracy theory label when information
makes them uncomfortable I'm only
telling you things that are already out
there in the public domain there are a
number of names out there already of
people who by the way are connected to
the Obama team one person who's being
represented by Obama's former White
House lawyer Tucker was present at a
meeting Bob Muller's investigating a
meeting right now with Russians that
they're claiming has to do with Trump
but the meeting was with people who were
actually connected to the Clintons one
of the guys at the meeting is literally
being represented by Obama's former
White House lawyer who by the way worked
with Andy Weissman who's working with
Bob Muller on the Special Counsel when
they were on the Enron
prosecution this is a big contaminated
witch's brew of people who are all
connected to each other and in some ways
not surprising because they always
accuse you of what they're doing
Allah Eric Schneiderman I mean it's a
very thank you Dan it was great to see
you tonight I appreciate that
yes sir